[Musique]
quel pays est le plus grand producteur
de noisettes au monde la turquie avec
ses 400 mille petits vergers familiaux
la turquie fournit 70% de toutes les
noisettes du monde c'est principalement
là bas que s'approvisionne les grands
fabricants de tartinades aux noisettes
et autres bonbons praliné mais cette
dépendance envers un seul pays rend
l'industrie vulnérables par exemple en
le gel printanier la grêle ont presque
anéanti la récolte turc et fait monter
en flèche le prix de la petite noix pour
diversifier les sources
d'approvisionnement
plusieurs pays dans le monde ont été
ciblés dont le canada les noisettes sont
déjà cultivées à petite échelle en
colombie britannique
mais c'est dans le sud de l'ontario que
l'on déploie de grands efforts pour
planter de nouvelles noise ray le climat
y est idéal pour cette culture et on
trouve là bas depuis 2006 une grande
usine de transformation de noisettes en
2017 l'ontario comptait 200 hectares de
noise ray l'objectif des gouvernements
et de l'industrie est de voir ce nombre
atteindre 6000 hectares en 2027
pour les agriculteurs une fois
l'investissement initial absorber les
noisettes sont une petite mine d'or la
même superficie rapporte quatre fois
plus que le maïs sans compter qu un
noisetier peut vivre
à 100 ans
[Musique]